the bella russian police have resorted
to familiar tactics
picking people seemingly at random off
the street more than a hundred arrests
this sunday
unnecessary scuffles with an entirely
peaceful crowd
the same tactic they used in the days
immediately after the disputed and
clearly rigged election three weeks ago
with heavy police and military
reinforcements rolling into minsk
earlier in the day
a sign the president is increasingly
panicked
[Applause]
huge numbers came out for the third
sunday running the crowds a hint more
courageous this week
face to face this time with the riot
police guarding the presidential palace
[Applause]
the chance familiar ones that this
president they've had for 26 years must
go
but to mark the occasion of his 66th
birthday happy birthday you rant
they said i came here to express my
disagreement with the results of the
election and express my solidarity with
the detained people and political
prisoners
i stand for peace for belarus but not
for lukashenko
president lukashenko chose to mark the
day in the attire of one of his riot
policemen
full body armor assault rifle in hand
earlier russia's president vladimir
putin had called to congratulate him
and invite him to moscow in the coming
weeks a movement which started simply to
protest fraudulent election results
now shifting into the kremlin's lap
lukashenko seeking out russia's help
and president putin seemingly happy to
oblige
for now just verbal there is the offer
of police reinforcements on the table if
the protests escalate
the people of belarus have done their
best to keep things peaceful
aware of what their president is capable
of but lukashenko's warlike demeanor
does not bode well
and his people show no sign of backing
down
donna magnus sky news moscow